[Music]
the be active local hero award
recognizes and celebrates individual
achievements that encourage others to be
active
alolog the winner of the 2021 award
perfectly embodies the be active spirit
having been a promoter of physical
activity throughout estonia for years
aloe has taken on the challenge of
making movement and being active a
natural part of the daily routine for
all estonians promoting movement as a
lifestyle aloe created a new initiative
for indoor health trails within
buildings in 2015.
the idea was simple if people spend much
of the day indoors we should give them
opportunities to move and be active
there
the initiative has grown immensely since
with over 130 health trails encouraging
over 100 000 people every day to engage
in indoor exercise be it in corporate
offices schools or universities
aloe's indoor health trails make clever
use of stairs corridors and courtyards
to encourage people of all ages to move
and be active
aloe's impact goes beyond the indoors
his estonian health trail foundation
oversees a network of 122 outdoor trails
across estonia with over 1 100
kilometers of trails for running biking
and skiing
with more than 6 million visits a year
the trails contribute to a healthier
happier and more active estonian society
the impact of indoor and outdoor health
stay is that we are really close to
people all the time that's the key how
we make
moving as a lifestyle to all estonians
i think benefits of being active on
daily basis it makes us all stronger
happier better people and if we are
healthy and happy then we have more
healthy ears and that's all we need
[Music]
you